en su justificación de la invasión rusa
de ucrania el presidente ruso vladimir
putin se preocupa en invertir los
papeles a siento que el agresor parezca
al agredido putin se ha presentado como
el liberador de ucrania sobre todo
cuando afirmó su voluntad de proteger al
pueblo que sufre la intimidación y el
genocidio del régimen de kiev esto
derrocharse en ningún grupo de pruebas
además cuando el mandatario ruso habla
de la desnazificación de ucrania está de
nuevo creando un discurso falso aunque
hay grupos de extremistas en ucrania
como en el resto de europa el país no
está de ninguna manera bajo un yugo
completamente nazi a lo largo de los dos
años de la pandemia international facts
a king network una red que reúne a
verificadores de todo el mundo recopiló
más de 10.000 bulos relacionados con el
coi 19 mientras que sólo en cinco días
desde la invasión rusa a ucrania están
esto se recogió cinco días después ya se
han detectado más de 500 noticias falsas
al respecto y para ello entonces quiero
saludar en ese momento a nuestro segundo
invitado del día él es andrés jiménez
coordinador de maldito bulo gracias
andrés por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 en una situación de
guerra y de conflicto político de
intereses como lo estamos viendo en este
momento que es tan difícil se vuelve el
trabajo de verificar esta información
andrés
muy complicado sobre todo hay que tener
en cuenta que tenemos una desventaja
respecto a los bulos que es que crear
una desinformación cuesta nada apenas
unos segundos con muy pocos recursos sin
embargo el desmentido que hacemos los
verificadores a veces es algo que puede
prolongarse durante varios días eso sí
hay unos muy sencillos desinformación es
muy sencillas que pueden desmentir la
gente desde casa con herramientas muy
simples como esa búsqueda inversa de
imagen que nos permite saber el contexto
de una foto que hemos recibido a través
de vías como whatsapp a eso quería
llegar entonces andrés como contrastar y
como contrarrestan ustedes esta lluvia
de información y cuál es el método que
utilizan para poder verificar la y
también profundicemos un poco de las
personas la gente del común que pues no
son periodistas y nos están
especializadas en información también
cómo pueden hacer para para buscar una
información verídica
si uno puede pensar que las herramientas
que se utilizan para desmentir una
desinformación son muy complejas
efectivamente las hay pero hay una que
tenemos todos también la gente que nos
está viendo desde casa que es la
observación es normal que en momentos
así cuando recibimos imágenes muy
simbólicas chocantes que despiertan
muchas emociones dentro de nosotros
queramos compartirlas al momento eso no
hay que hacerlo tenemos que parar y
observar esa imagen que hemos recibido
podemos observar el idioma en el que
están hablando en el vídeo podría darnos
alguna pista observar el entorno o si
hay algún coche mirar la matrícula
porque es muy posible que esas pistas
nos sirvan para utilizar y para
desmentir que un vídeo en concreto haya
sido grabado ahora mismo en ucrania son
muchas las desinformaciones de imágenes
sacadas de contexto que estamos viendo
así que mucho cuidado con ellas qué daño
le hace la desinformación a la sociedad
y también a los a ambos lados de este
conflicto por ejemplo hablamos de rusia
y ucrania centrándonos y actualizándolo
en el conflicto que estamos viendo la
actualidad
hace un daño tremendo y no sólo a las
personas que están más afectadas por
esta situación ahora mismo seguro que
gran parte de las personas que nos están
viendo lo hacen desde una posición un
poco más alejada del conflicto pero
todos tenemos nuestra responsabilidad
porque el hecho de compartir una
desinformación nos convierte en un
eslabón de toda esa avalancha que
estamos viendo yo no me quiero imaginar
a alguien que tenga una persona ahora
mismo escondida en un búnker en kiev que
reciba un vídeo como estamos viendo
apocalíptico de formaciones rusas
invadiendo la ciudad eso tiene un
impacto psicológico tremendo es un arma
más como cualquier otra guerra y desde
luego pues puede ser muy grave y se está
utilizando en este conflicto como
estamos viendo respetar no andrés
también los sentimientos las personas y
ante una duda y no tener una información
verificada pues no compartirlo porque
mira el daño sobre todo emocional que
las guerras generan pero centrándonos
ahora en el discurso del presidente ruso
vladimir putin de la desnazificación de
ucrania y el supuesto genocidio cometido
en la región del dom base por el
gobierno y ucrania como se puede
verificar esto es
imposible digamos verificar una una
ideología o estas acusaciones ahora cómo
se puede hacer
es muy complicado sobre todo porque es
una afirmación muy amplia en todo caso
nosotros lo que sí hemos visto en estos
últimos días es que a raíz de esa
narrativa de ese discurso han empezado a
circular todo tipo de imágenes montajes
de militares y ucranianos sosteniendo la
bandera nazi sosteniendo una esvástica
entonces es la prueba de que como a raíz
de según qué tipo de discursos la
desinformación los bulos concretos que
recibimos todos los días van a ir detrás
entonces desde luego son contenidos que
nos llegan a través de whatsapp de las
redes sociales que lo que hacen es un
poco intentar reafirmar esos discursos y
también andrés ante la salida de los
medios de comunicación oficiales rusos
de plataformas digitales alegando
desinformación por parte de estas
cadenas cuál es su postura realmente
estos medios desinforman es una medida
acertada o posiblemente pudieran estar
atacando la libertad de prensa
ahora mismo lo que estamos viendo al
menos en españa- el verdadero problema
de la desinformación son esos contenidos
que nos llegan por whatsapp y por redes
sociales nosotros ahora mismo tenemos 70
bulos desmentidos que principalmente han
llegado a través de esas vías lo que sí
creo que es importante es que ya sea una
decisión que tomen las plataformas o una
institución o cualquier otro gobierno
esa decisión se tiene que tomar con
transparencia se tiene que decir
claramente porque se ha tomado esta
decisión cómo se ha tomado y qué
criterios se han utilizado y una vez se
hayan respondido a esas preguntas
esas mismas normas se tienen que se
tienen que aplicar a todo el mundo la
transparencia es crucial porque no son
los medios de comunicación sino también
las plataformas se juegan su
credibilidad en momentos como estos
andrés esto podría ser entonces una
decisión no política
ese es una pregunta que tienen que
responder quienes están tomando esas
decisiones nosotros ya te digo en estos
momentos los contenidos que más estamos
desmintiendo no vienen por esa vía sino
a través de redes sociales y vías en los
que nosotros formamos parte activamente
como usuarios y como miembros de la
sociedad civil andrés gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 un gran abrazo
desde la ciudad de bogotá